in one of the all-time worst moves
youtube
ponders deleting the dislike button from
the platform
in response to creator feedback around
well-being and targeted dislike
campaigns we're testing a few new
designs
that don't show the public dislike count
if you're part of this small experiment
you might spot one of these designs in
the coming weeks and then they show you
this beautiful
dystopia of where you can only see the
positives only the good
guys youtube is a platform that's
advertiser frilly and they want everyone
to know it there's
nobody's unhappy okay every this is
everyone all the time with every video
hey
there's um there's bad people on the
platform
hey there's a thought on the platform
everybody's happy
no nobody's upset about it guys this is
the all-time
worst decision youtube will make if they
go through this obviously they're
testing it right now but they're
considering clearly
uh for a more widespread push out but i
want to talk to you guys
today about why okay so first of all
is it all because of youtube rewind
uh because as you guys know they got
blasted
oh that's hot that's hot
probably not to be honest they listen to
a narrow set of creators
and some of those creators aren't very
well liked by the youtube community
as a whole now does that suck
yes do you get rid of a primary feature
of your platform because a few people
that you listen to complained about it
no of course not
but youtube is so disconnected from
their audience that they think to
themselves yeah
we've heard it from like a few of the
top creators don't like being disliked
bomb to their video
so we're just going to get rid of this
all together this is like
uh when netflix deleted the dislike
button because amy schumer had a bad
special
it's like yeah sometimes people swing
and they miss we don't need to protect
them from it they're big people they're
grown
they can handle it and if they're not
why are they making public things
on public platforms listen there's
already a way
to get rid of the dislike button it's
called
disabling the dislike button all this is
doing
is hiding the fact that other people
want to hide it it's basically like
saying
everyone has to pretend like they can't
handle criticism because
a few people don't want to be known for
publicly signaling that hey i can't
handle criticism
so now this would roll out would mean
that literally no one could
can dislike anything ever um
look i i don't know why this sounds
shocking to say but genuinely
bad things exist right and it should be
okay to talk about those things and it
should be okay
to signal publicly that those bad things
are bad especially on a platform like
youtube which is so
like feedback driven so user driven like
the whole comment thing was
revolutionary you used to just have
cable tv nobody could ever say anything
youtube broke that and said no we're
gonna give the power for people to not
only give feedback but to see what other
people are doing
so this is a huge reversal or would be a
huge reversal if they go through with it
um on that sort of mission and ethos
and the question is like for what end
look
wars exist genocide exists you know
scammers exist
a bunch of things that i can't say the
name of exists because i'll get
demonetized which is
absolutely asinine but you know these
things should be allowed to be talked
about and we should be allowed to
you the viewers should be allowed to
publicly you know signal your disdain
for them and i get it that sometimes
sucks for
us the creator look listen i made a
whole video on public shaming
i got publicly shamed the next month
that was great a million viewed video
like uh you know 60 70 dislikes i ended
up apologizing for what i did
did it feel great not a great feeling to
have everyone hate you
but would i have rather no dislikes be
able to show
up no of course not because actually the
crowd is right
and the crowd's not always right but in
that case the crowd was right i was in
the wrong
and i apologize for it and it's fine we
moved on i reflected
i got feedback i reflected i said you
guys are right
i don't always do that sometimes i get
like on my david ike video
it's well over 50 dislikes i'm never
going to take that video down because i
stand by what i said so but it's
important that i have that feedback from
you the audience sometimes you guys are
gonna say steven this is you look like a
jackass
and that's okay you should be allowed to
say that i won't love it
i it's every time honestly no matter how
much a creator says they don't care
about that
it's a little bit you know it's like ow
it's like ow
kind of hurts it's it's just like ah
that doesn't feel good but
do we get rid of it all just so that
i don't have to feel look i get publicly
lauded
ninety percent of the time that's too
much already
i mean my my ego is going to get out of
control if that tips to a hundred
percent
honestly quite frankly look i needed a
few
you know bad videos every now and then
to put me back in check remind me where
i sit
i am an f list youtuber that's where i
belong and if i
get out of that watch out if i get out
of that realm and i start thinking of
myself more than that watch out i'm
gonna go nuts
like you ever hear the expression uh
like they just are surrounded by yes men
that's what we're gonna create literally
there will be no recourse for like hey
that's actually not cool hey cause
people can just they'll just delete
comments just
curate their own special bubble it's so
weird man
that we want to do this it's like
everything in human psychology would
tell us yeah this isn't great
just telling people all the time who
already are like
attention [ __ ] you know narcissist
already
telling them oh yeah you'd never have a
problem that's a good idea
dude anyone with over 100 000
subscribers on this platform needs a
reality check every now and then quite
frankly
myself included okay i'm just gonna kick
it straight with you guys
uh it's good every now and then just to
get reminded just get a little
up all right we're back okay and we are
uh
back ladies and gentlemen thank you for
that reality check and we're back to
making videos
but you don't have that you don't have
any mechanism for that and you're just
you're
it's like a balloon that just keeps
getting inflated your ego just like yeah
you're doing a great job
you've never made a mistake come on we
know that's not true
so why are we gonna make that like in
the feedback mechanism
it's just such a blunt move to like fix
a really small
problem like it's like banning tide pods
because some
kid sticks one in their mouth every now
and then it's like banning donations
because there are political grifters
it's like banning free speech because
some people believe
that lizards like run the entire world
like yeah i don't agree with those
things but
what we don't have the ability to call
bad things bad like
no we we don't need to throw the baby
out with the bathwater kind of thing
it's one of the things that makes
youtube such a special place is that you
can interact you can see what people are
thinking you get that feedback
in a way that no other medium does
like you know so many platforms have
been removing
likes dislikes and it's such a mistake
i think uh for for things like youtube
where you're sharing important ideas
like
dude how are we supposed to determine
the worth of an idea look if somebody
just comes randomly talking about
how it is a hoax blah blah you should be
allowed to dislike that
right or if you think it is and you go
to a
video you're allowed to dislike that too
it's
let the people decide i just hate this
man this like
overreach of oh you're not allowed to
dislike things anymore guys
bad things exist you should be able to
express your opinion you should be able
to talk about it
even if it makes one of us creators go
oh
it's fine i don't know that's just me
that's just what i think let me know
what you think in the comments below
and uh that's basically it see you guys
next time i know what you need
this ain't what it seems nothing but a
trick trying to sell me on a dream but
that was where you lost me wake up and
smell the coffee